[Música]
l
ah
[Música]
desde que usó twitter descubrirla e
informa e informa es el usuario de la
real academia española de la lengua real
para los españoles tiene tal vez un
significado especial para nosotros no
tiene tanta connotación real del rey
parece como muy importante y re informa
hace un tiempo ha comenzado a recibir
consultas acerca del cambio en la lengua
la lengua cambia así lo sabemos desde
que somos chicos vamos a la escuela
aprendemos la lengua del quijote la
lengua de nuestros abuelos la lengua
nuestra
y esos cambios parecían ser cambios que
se hacían por grandes períodos de siglos
a siglos
menéndez pidal un historiador muy
importante del español hablaba de la
plurisecular duración del cambio
lingüístico
pero llegado con los nuevos tiempos
llegó el siglo 20 el siglo 21 los nuevos
medios de comunicación y los cambios en
el mundo comenzaron a hacer cambios muy
rápidos
y la lengua acompañado esos cambios
tan veloces entonces comenzó a tener
sentido pensar más allá de la lengua los
cambios son solo en la lengua o los
cambios implican también a la sociedad
y ahí comenzamos a pensar el cambio en
serio
si esta lengua va acompañando el cambio
en la sociedad empezamos a ver la
importancia que la lengua tiene el valor
enorme que esta lengua tiene y yo me
pregunto que me importa más me importa
el cambio en la lengua o me importa el
cambio en la sociedad
y de nuevo escuchamos a la radio que
dice el lenguaje inclusivo no tiene
necesidad en el español no es necesario
la lengua española no lo requiere
yo digo otra vez que me importa más y
pienso en la gente eso es lo que me
importa la gente que habla
cotidianamente la gente que necesita
hablar
la lengua sola como ente autónomo no
existe la lengua existe en los hablantes
que la usan cotidianamente para crear
una realidad y para crearse a sí mismos
como sociedad también
y escucho
nuevos comentarios
surge allá por comienzos de los 2000
cuando en nuestro país llegó la reforma
educativa los chicos y las chicas los
alumnos y las alumnas los profesores y
las profesoras al principio aparece un
lenguaje tedioso pesado
pero poco a poco fuimos dándonos cuenta
de que esa forma era más abarcativa de
que esa forma parecía no dejar a nadie
fuera a nadie realmente oa los nadies
que considerábamos en ese momento
surgen nuevas voces y aparece arroba
aparece x casi por la misma época arroba
y x son muy útiles para el lenguaje
escrito pero en la lengua oral que
hacemos como pronunciamos esas equis o
esas arrugas y de nuevo escuchamos a la
radio
la lengua española tiene género
masculino y femenino
si gramaticalmente nosotros no vamos a
discutir porque en este momento no es la
gramática lo que nos importa nos importa
la gente que habla y la gente habla
porque necesita decir algo y entonces
aparece una nueva discusión
hablamos de género o hablamos de sexo
y en las personas hablamos de género
y los géneros no son dos hace muchos
años que no son dos alguna vez fueron
dos
tal vez nunca
y acá podemos ubicar al lenguaje
inclusivo a las nuevas voces que se
alzan con estos movimientos sociales
últimos y aparece la e la y parece ser
muy generosa la e parece inclusiva
abarcativa
de nuevo hay discusiones
el lenguaje inclusivo no sirve para nada
dice una gran gran lingüista la
verdadera inclusión no está ahí la
verdadera inclusión no está en el
lenguaje la verdadera inclusión está va
a estar cuando los hombres y las mujeres
accedamos a los mismos trabajos y
cobremos los mismos sueldos
y yo digo sí claro tiene razón
pero si la lengua crea la sociedad y me
crea a mí misma como miembro de esa
sociedad entonces tal vez podemos
comenzar por acá podemos comenzar por
crear con nuestra lengua una sociedad
inclusiva en donde expresemos la
inclusión y donde tanto nombrar la
inclusión finalmente podamos lograr una
sociedad en donde hombres y mujeres y
todos los colectivos que vamos
identificando cada vez con más letras
con un más que nos lleva al infinito
para la libertad de todos y de cada uno
y entonces si accedamos todos y todas
todas
a los mismos trabajos y a los mismos
sueldos y que cuando se busque un
trabajo
no se busque a una persona perdón no se
busque a un hombre oa una mujer no se
busca un género se busque a una persona
y el sueldo por ese trabajo sea el
sueldo por ese trabajo y no el sueldo
por una forma de hablar por una forma de
vestirse o de peinarse o cualquier otro
rasgo externo sin sentido
entonces yo creo que es el momento de
que podamos partir de la palabra esta
palabra que tiene un poder enorme y que
nos puede permitir transformar la
realidad actual pensando en una
verdadera sociedad inclusiva en donde
hoy será la e la que nos convoque y
probablemente dentro de un tiempo las
nuevas generaciones porque siempre los
cambios vienen de las nuevas
generaciones son esas nuevas
generaciones sin miedo las generaciones
atrevidas en el verdadero sentido de la
palabra las que nos van a ayudar a
construir esta sociedad inclusiva con
mayúsculas la verdadera y completa
sociedad inclusiva
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah